i'm gonna take the phone call of one of
the best running backs in the national
football league as a matter of fact pro
football focus
i saw their tweet uh this gentleman
leads the nfl
in uh all running backs uh for first
down rushes 25
touchdowns rushes rushing touchdown six
21 missed tackles
forced by him and
269 yards after contract yards those
are leading the national football league
of the minnesota vikings fresh off of
his two touchdown
130 yard performance fresh off of his
181 yard performance
he's dalvin cook how are you calvin
how you doing rich better for talking to
you dalvin cook better for talking to
you
um to what what do you owe the last
couple of weeks you've got you've got it
uh um
you know you've gotten in the end zone
in previous weeks but you've really
kicked it up a notch in terms of the
rushing yards to what do you owe
this calvin
um you know it's all credit to the old
line receivers
you know getting this thing done and you
know our season hasn't started how we
wanted to this part but you know we just
kept chipping away and guys just been
working
and been getting some yards out there
for me and i just been in attack mode
you know trying to get a win and get
this thing rolling for us
and coach has been doing a great job of
staying on us
well in terms of the offense do you feel
like um
a switch has been flipped that we didn't
see say in indianapolis or in week one
against green bay would you say that
dalvin cook yeah it was just really
about the time of possession and cause
jim
gave us a heads up before this thing
even started you know it was going to be
about time of possession and all these
games and
the first couple of games we got behind
so fast to uh
we had to throw the ball pretty much the
whole game and you know that's not us
you know that's not standard rhythm and
staying on schedule and you know that's
when we got out of whack and i think
these last couple of games we've been
able to ground it out and
you know keep curtin some manageable
situations so he can make some throws
and
that's how we'd be successful well in
terms of you know
um running the ball more as you
mentioned that mike zimmer stresses it
um and and did is that something that
was told to you say before week three in
tennessee
i mean or or did you just get in the
huddle and go okay that's another one
for me i mean it's
how does that work darwin yeah it's kind
of going with the flow
you know but we all know you know coach
didn't want to play good defense
you know running football that minute
that clock you know limits other team
possessions so
we knew what was going on we knew we
wasn't getting that getting that many
possessions so we knew we had to run the
football
to keep teams honest more and i think
we've been doing a great job
great job these last few weeks and um
being on three
what was the conversation amongst you
and your teammates oh and three
heading onto that field against an
equally own three and desperate team in
houston
yeah it was a reality check um you know
everybody
you know look each other in in the
mirror and hold your brother
responsible and you know i i like about
this team because you know we could have
easily said we're going three
no things not going our way we're gonna
hang our heads but i seen this team come
back to work
you know after a tough loss and we
played tennessee and just do nothing but
accept the coaching and just
and just go out there and work and you
know we got the results that we needed
well i mean when you say results it's
not just results that you needed on the
field and results that you needed
in terms of a stat sheet it's also
results that you needed from the
coronavirus
the fact that tennessee starts testing
positive and then there's an outbreak
and your vectors crossed with theirs on
the field what was
your first thought when you heard about
tennessee starting to test positive
with uh alarming numbers dalvin
yeah it was scary you know i don't i
definitely don't take this thing lightly
i take it as serious as i can
you know i try to be as safe as i can
and you know i pray for those guys
that you know that got it and you know
it was it was scary for us because you
know
we was out there banging with those guys
you know sweating with those guys and
you never know how this thing can can
can get
in your body so we never we was always
you know alert of the of the coronavirus
but you know
playing a team that that contracted so
many viruses was was scary for us
well and again uh you know i'm i'm being
tested um
every um couple of weeks and i get the
test
results back on my cell phone in the
email and it takes about a second and a
half before the
uh avatar or photograph that says that
you're either positive or negative to
pop up and i just look at that thing and
it's a very long second i'm not gonna
lie to you
and all i've got to do is just broadcast
um
you know not not not play a football
game and get ready for a football game i
mean
the uncertainty how did that play on
your team as you were getting ready for
the texans
dalvin um last week
overall was crazy because we had to go
different protocols and
we had to take the two tests the tests
we had to wait for it to go inside the
building each morning
and then we had to take the test for our
daily test so you know just waiting
for that test to get your results back
kind of anxious you know
you nervous it's just the whole the
whole thing is a new normal for us and
we're still adapting
even though it's week five so you know
waiting for those results and
just you know just just being in that
environment
you know it's different for us and again
i i i asked this question of you i mean
you're
you're a uh pro bowl caliber player
you're as big a name
out there in the nfl today dalvin and um
you know so i'll ask this question of
you um and i would ask it of any player
i have on but
your your your opinion considered is
considerable here
because fans are asking me when they
hear against stefan gilmore test
positive today
in new england we're seeing more tests
coming back positive from tennessee
after a couple days of negative and some
fans are
saying would the nfl just stop like just
stop for a week or two
to get everything settled and get
everybody negative again and start again
because we saw
three straight weeks after uh uh a
training period where
where everyone was negative how would
you respond to that
in minnesota as a player in the nfl if
somebody just came to you and said hey
i know you're all negative and i know
you just got through that week and i
know you just gotta win but
we're stopping for a couple weeks how
would how would you respond to that
darwin um i'm with whatever you know to
keep everybody safe and that's the main
thing
you know before the season started you
know i know the league and the nflpa was
kind of up ahead because you know they
had to come agreements on the protocol
but you know i'm i'm with whatever
you know the league comes up with to
keep everybody safe because that's what
it comes to an end of the day
because you know you had guys opt out to
keep to keep themselves safe and you had
guys that
you know stated stayed into this thing
to play you know to say you know
i'm accepting the lead protocol and you
know i and i definitely believe it's
going to keep me safe so
you know whatever protocol that they
have set up for us moving forward you
know i'm all for if it's going to keep
us safe
and just dalvin cook here on the rich
eisen show and then again just
your journey in general um uh you
struck it you finally got that long-term
contract
after again um you know a journey from
florida state you weren't drafted as
high
as your talent deserved um and now here
you are
a top running back in the national
football league not just in terms of
statistics but in terms of your contract
what was that moment
like for you to get that 60 plus million
dollar deal placed in front of you for
your john hancock dalvin cook
yeah it was it was it was unbelievable
you know some days i wake up
and you know i still feel like a dream
that i'm living in and
you know like you said my journey you
know it has been had some bumps in the
road no injury here
and like you said the drive process you
know everything that came with it
you know i just wanted to just wanted to
work after all those things i just
wanted to go back to on the field and
just and just work as hard as i can and
you know if anybody listening to this
you know i just
just put the hard work in don't worry
about the ending outcome
you know just just put your head down
you know every day you know it's gonna
be some tough days just go to work
and you know you ain't gonna get the
outcome you want some days but
you know you keep working you know
things will fall through for you and
in terms of again we're living crazy
times dalvin obviously and your contract
you get it on uh or signing it or it's
official on a saturday you got to play
the packers to kick off week one in a
pandemic
on a sunday uh that said um did you buy
anything did you get anything for
anybody
uh to to celebrate or somebody that's uh
important to you that deserved um
something based on their support of you
anybody
in that respect calvin
yeah um you know i got my mom and my dad
back home man
you know i haven't i haven't purchased
anything yet you know because i'm really
not a guy
big of a spence or you know expensive
guy you know
i'm a low maintenance person but you
know i'm definitely going to buy my mom
and my dad a new home you know once his
time
and you know that was definitely one of
my goals
when i was growing up to always you know
redirect
my mom and dad was living so you know
that's still the thing on my agenda
so that's what you grew up saying i want
to get to
the nfl um and help my parents
and get a better life for them and now
you're going to achieve that that is so
amazing darling there's just no other
way to put it
i appreciate it just amazing dalvin cook
amazing
uh and let's just a few minutes i have
left uh
let's give the vikings fans some some
hope out there dalvin as you know the
skull chants are
are just piped in these days um
so what what what can we glean here
i mean from this w and and cousins
finding thielen with more regularity the
kid from lsu justin jefferson beginning
to flash you
getting the end zone and putting
together some rushing yards of
triple digits uh is this is this a
turnaround here for
for the vikes yeah um
you know viking fans you know you know
all the fans you know that that tune
into the vikings you know
this team right here is is a different
thing that they're used to seeing
over the years you know we got different
players young players we got guys
stepping in different roles
and you know it's been a different
off-season so you know being patient as
they can with us
and you know we're going to get this
thing turned around and i think you know
sunday
was a good example of us gaining
confidence for the younger guys
for the for the whole team and you know
moving forward
you know you got guys like i said young
guys stepping up and they know they
could make that play
and they've seen the play being made you
know so just just be patient with us man
we're working and
you know we're going to get this thing
turned around and start winning some
more football games for you guys
does kirk hear the media footsteps does
he i mean you ever have these
conversations with him off
offline that i'm asking you now to bring
online
does he hear it yeah you know you know
being around being around kirk you know
this is a real
realistic answer you know being around
kurt you know i think
kurt does a great job of blocking out
the noise and
you know i think being at the
quarterback position
you know you can take as much as you can
because you know that's the position
that they held to the highest standard
and you know kirk does a great job of
just coming back to work
and blocking out the noise so you know i
think he definitely hears it
but you know that's why i love curt so
much you know he blocks the noise out
and just just go back to work
well this is a big week nationally
televised games sunday night football
doesn't get much bigger than that
do you do you sense it when it leads up
to it and you
you know that uh that eyes are on you
when you get out there
dalvin you know what yeah you got to
come at home
keep the most in check you know you're
ready to play on the tuesday and
wednesday you know you got to kind of
keep the motions in check because it's
going to be a long week
and you know we know this is a big week
you know we know the team we playing
we've had to plan the team for about
three years now since i've been here
and you know we just looking to go out
there and play a clean football game
and win a game and come back to
minnesota and and you know that that's
just not going to take me
me saying that's going to take a hard
work of preparation
all week and you know going out there
and getting it done well not to add any
extra pressure to alvin cook
but i think you can handle this
information uh my son xander 12 years
old
um you were the first overall selection
for him
fourth in his fantasy draft um i'm the
commissioner of this league
um i see all the trade offers that he
receives the number of trade offers he's
received for your services
that have been rejected i've lost count
um
he he loves him some dalvin cook so zan
wanted me to give you a shout out
the joey specials is the name of the
team you don't just play for the vikings
dalvin you play for the joey specials as
well okay just want to let you know
shout out to the george bashes man shout
out to the little man and i appreciate
it for having you on this team
you got it yeah zan loves dalvin cook he
does he also loves aaron
jones that's why his his fantasy team is
better than his dads to be very honest
with you right now but it's all good
it's all good thanks for the call dalvin
and thanks for doing it i appreciate you
it's all the time always
you got it right back at you that's
dalvin cook that's dominic cook
another guy whose world we are paying
rent in right now hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here